president trump's communications team
can't set the record straight on the
president's health
trump takes an ill-advised ride around
the hospital and democrats try to
conceal their glee as they politically
maneuver i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn stand up for your digital
rights visit expressvpn.com
and we'll get to all of the news in just
a moment but the news may have you
thinking these days a little bit about
your health
and here's the thing you should get in
shape you should have done it before you
should definitely
do it now but getting in shape does not
have to be about losing a specific
amount of weight or magic number on the
scale
instead it's about building healthier
habits seriously like as somebody who
lost some weight during the pandemic i
can certainly credit at least in large
part
nume why because it helped change my
habits with regards to my diet and my
exercise
nume is the habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses
based in psychology noom teaches you why
you do the things you do and then
empowers you with the tools you need to
break bad habits and replace them with
better ones noon doesn't tell you what
to do and what not to do instead it
teaches you how to look inside your own
mind
and make better decisions for yourself
they also have one of the biggest most
accurate food databases available lets
you track meal habits visualize portion
sizes
and see calorie density at a glance
you're human if you go off track that's
not
really anything to be ashamed about
they'll give you tips to help you get
back on track
tomorrow and you can chat with a goal
specialist in neum community to get and
give help to people going through the
same things because studies show that
when you work with other people
you tend to do better you don't have to
change everything in one day small steps
make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noon
that's n-o-m-com
shapiro again that's noom.com shapiro
n-o-o-m
dot com shapiro go check them out right
now okay so first
let's start with the state of the race
because thank god it looks like the
president is going to be fine it looks
like he's going to be
totally okay you know we will watch the
health as it progresses over the course
of the next week we'll get to his health
condition in just a moment because it
turns out that it's really more about
the sort of topsy-turvy calms of it all
the communications of it all
over the weekend rather than the
president's actual health
but the state of the race seems to be
breaking very strongly in joe biden's
direction that is not a great shock
after president trump's very bizarre
debate performance last week
and then after his covet diagnosis you
would expect that the polls would begin
to open
a fair amount and as you see from the
new wall street journal nbc news poll
this is exactly what you see joe biden
now leads the president 53-39 among
registered voters in the new poll now
registered voters isn't really what
you're looking for really you're looking
for likely voters
that is a large lead however for biden
he has increased the lead from an eight
point advantage last month
to a 14 point lead today that came just
before trump tested positive for covered
which of course was bad news
for trump the survey actually found that
the individual
news event the debate was having a
material effect on trump's political
standing
at least for the moment one of the
reasons again was because
trump sort of reinforced the fact that
he was at the center of the race as i
have literally been saying for years at
this point
if this race is a referendum on trump
he's going to lose if this race is a
referendum on biden
and the radicalism of the democrats then
maybe the democrats lose
but there are certain areas where trump
is really starting to trail heavily
he was always trailing among women in
this particular survey he's trailing 60
to 33
among women more importantly among
elderly people
he's really dropping in terms of his
level of support and he won elderly
voters last time right now he is losing
elderly voters pretty significantly
and even in this poll which was before
trump got coveted
the poll showed that 52 of americans
believed that biden would be better at
handling cobit 52
35 so all of this is is bad news
for republicans obviously it's bad news
for the senate the worse the president
performs if it's a close election and he
loses maybe the republicans hold the
senate right now republicans in order to
hold the senate you need to hold five
of eight contested seats right now that
looks
pretty dicey they would need to hold
among others colorado
iowa montana arizona
maine north carolina a lot of very very
contested seats a lot of hotly fraud
seats
right there so we'll see how how all of
this
turns out it is likely that the
president's poll numbers are going to
drop further in the immediate aftermath
of the covet diagnosis specifically
because there is a poll from abc news
episodes that shows that nearly three in
four people think
that that trump did not take the
appropriate precautions regarding
coveted which again is not a shock
considering the kind of rhetoric he puts
out there as i pointed out
last week after the covet diagnosis what
the government has done is not the same
thing
as what trump expresses when he is
number one on the stump and number two
in his sort of general attitude whenever
he talks about masks for example he'll
say things like
i'll wear a mask if i have to but you
know people are wearing too many masks
and they're
not really that great okay there's a way
to talk about masks that shows that you
take them seriously and then there's a
way to talk about them that shows that
you don't take them particularly
seriously
two things can be true at once one trump
can have handled his own rhetoric on
kovid in a very bad way
and two the media are completely insane
right both of these things
are absolutely true which brings us to
this weekend so i had the
wonderful experience of not being online
during this weekend which
honestly it was great and one of the
reasons it was great is because i missed
all of the chaos
and discombobulation see i came off my
my jewish holiday late last night
and my first thing was okay is trump
okay right checked he was okay and i
thought okay well that's the news
no wrong i am because we live inside a
reality tv show
and the only thing that matters is how
the media cover what trump is doing
today and what trump is doing today and
so what you got over the weekend
is really in microcosm the last four
years of the news cycle
which is trump does a bunch of things
some of which are good and some of which
are tremendously ill-advised and the
media treat all of them
individually as the end of the world and
when you come away at the end
trump's basically okay the media is
basically okay everything's basically
okay
right that was the story of the weekend
nonetheless two things can be true at
once there was a battery
in terms of exactly how this was handled
from the white house
without a doubt and also the media
decided to turn
everything even stuff that was
pre-approved with the health
professionals that had sort of decided
to turn everything
into some sort of crazy scandal
okay so let's begin with early on in the
weekend so so on friday president trump
cuts an 18 second video
just showing that he's okay then he
proceeds to get on
marine one and then he flies to the
hospital it is worth pointing out at
this point that jennifer rubin of the
washington post says why is he getting
in a helicopter why doesn't he just take
a car
probably it's because he's super sick so
you should take a car
the relevance of the car will become
apparent in just a moment okay so then
on saturday president trump puts out
another video and this one is a four
minute video because there are questions
about the 18 second video
is that all he could do right how sick
was he so on saturday he puts out a
second video
in which he speaks for four minutes and
he talks about how he's going to beat
this thing and he's learning about kobe
the hard way
and frankly he looks you know a fair bit
better than he did on friday
it's been a very interesting journey i
learned a lot about covid
i learned it by really going to school
this is the real school
this isn't the let's read the book
school and i get it and i understand it
and it's a very interesting thing and
i'm going to be letting you know about
it in the meantime
we love the usa and we love what's
happening thank you
okay so obviously he doesn't sound bad
there i mean he looks like he's pretty
high energy kind of typical trump he
looks like he's
getting through this thing the white
house then released pictures of trump
signing papers
and the media went crazy because oh my
god it looks like he's sending a blank
paper first of all it's not clear the
paper is blank number two
like he might be dying guys as far as
you know at this point
he could be dying so that seems like
that is a last priority
they also went crazy because there are
two pictures of him that were released
one of them he's wearing a jacket one of
them he is not wearing a jacket and
they're like he took those two minutes
apart
and then he pretended that that was him
doing work all day long
okay seriously it was amazing over the
weekend
members of the media were like you know
other people other presidents have lied
about their state of health in the past
woodrow wilson
fdr jfk i've seen presidents lie about
their health in the past but they're
good at it
well no the difference is that back then
the media were actually complicit in
lying about the health
of the president of the united states
when they felt that it had national
security implications here they're
obviously trying to pick apart
the health state of president trump
based on whether he's signing a blank
sheet of paper
or not okay so that was saturday
okay then on sundays we'll see president
trump decided
you know it's sunday let's go for a
drive we'll get to that in just one
second
first let's talk about the fact that
right now it's kind of an uncertain
business being a gun owner what i mean
by that is not that you shouldn't own a
gun i mean you should own a gun
but one of the big problems is that if
you don't know every legal in and out
about how to use your weapon
in case of self-defense you might find
yourself under arrest anyway and this is
why you need to help my friends
over at the u.s concealed carry
association it's not right for good
responsible americans to wind up in jail
or embroiled in a lawsuit for defending
themselves or their family in this day
you need a gun to protect yourself and
your your family and yourself and
you need to know how to use it and this
is why you should be joining up with the
us cca
right now they will give you a 100 free
guide the complete concealed carry and
family defense guide
when you text my name ben to 87 222
in that guide you will learn how to
detect attackers before they see you how
to survive a mass shooting the safest
and most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant
how to responsibly own and store a gun
even if you have little kids and a whole
lot more it's 164 pages it comes with a
bonus audio version so you can listen
whenever you want you'll get instant
access to that guide and a chance to win
a thousand bucks so you can buy a gun to
protect your family
text my name ben to 87 222 right now
again text ben
to 87 222. so it was a sunday and the
president was feeling
better and so he decided it was time for
a drive so he released another video in
which he said guys
you know what i'm missing all y'all and
sure i have
a window right here and i could just
like go there and open it up and just
wave to everybody like ronald's reagan
after he got shot in 1980
but instead i need to drive around in a
car
he's going riding in his automobile okay
so here was the video
of president trump riding around in his
[Applause]
car
there he is waving he's wearing a mask
inside the car and you have a bunch of
trump supporters outside cheering okay
everybody in the media went holy crazy
about this and you knew they would
right you knew they would which is why
was this like a wonderful idea on its
face
no i mean if you're sick the way you are
supposed to be sick with kovid is you're
supposed to quarantine
quarantining means you're not supposed
to do stuff like this right now again
jennifer rubin who five minutes before
was like why didn't you take a car to
the hospital now she's like why is he
even in a car at all
he should get back on marine one okay
but the rest of the media
again decided to go absolutely bananas
over this thing now again two
for the thousandth time two things can
be short ones is it a good idea
to get in a vehicle and drive around in
the vehicle while you have covid
the general answer is no it is not a
good idea to do this right we all made
fun of chris cuomo
when he had coveted and then he decided
to jet set out
to his second property and check the
place out while he had covet
but is it also true that the president
is likely working with medical
professionals when he decides to do this
of course that's true but it doesn't
matter our
our twitter medical professionals decide
to go absolutely nuts about this so dr
james
phillips md who's the chief of disaster
medicine at george washington universal
university emergency medicine and he is
the walter he's an attending at walter
reed which doesn't mean he's trump's
attending it just means he's
unattending at walter reed walter is a
very large hospital there are many
attendings so it wouldn't be too hard to
find some doctor
who presumably doesn't like trump very
much he tweeted out
every single person in the vehicle
during that completely unnecessary
presidential drive by
just now has to be quarantined for 14
days they might get sick
they may die for political theater
commanded by trump to put their lives at
risk
for theater this is insanity
okay and then you had dr liana wen who's
the contributing columnist
for the washington post and cnn medical
analyst
i believe former head of planned
parenthood correct uh so d liana wen
who again has her own political priors
she tweeted out if donald trump were my
patient in unstable condition
and contagious illness and he suddenly
left the hospital to go for a car ride
that endangers himself and others
i'd call security to restrain him then
perform a psychiatric evaluation to
examine his decision-making capacity
well then you're probably not like a
very good doctor because it turns out
that the walter reed physicians cleared
him to do this according to catherine
herridge
over at cbs doctors okay the president's
drive by supporters deputy press
secretary tells mark noller
appropriate precautions were taken in
the execution of this movement to
protect the president and those
supporting it including
personal protective equipment cleared by
the medical team as safe to do so
apparently the secret service agents
were not just wearing masks along with
trump they were also wearing goggles
they were also wearing
like full-on gowns basically they were
they're wearing whatever personal
protective equipment
they needed in order to be safe
and for all of the members of the media
who are fulminating look at secret
service secret service being put at risk
it's so terrible see again
this is a good idea by trump no it is
not actually but
with that said secret service you guys
are very very worried about the secret
service today let me just point out that
over the weekend
there are a bunch of black lives matter
protesters protesting and they're doing
it at the white house which means the
secret service is right there
and there are videos and photos of
people shouting directly in their faces
people screaming
directly in their faces and you guys
didn't have one word to say about the
safety and security of the secret
service agents
because apparently that's deeply
necessary it's very necessary to have
people scream without masks directly
in the face of secret service agents
because at least they are screaming for
racial justice or whatever
cause of the day is and so forgive me my
skepticism about your motives media when
you talk about how how deeply
you care about the protection of our
secret service agents
okay then my favorite thing the white
house correspondents association
they couldn't even get the message
straight so was it bad for trump to go
on the
drive or is it bad that he didn't invite
the press to also go along
with the drive according to the hill the
white house correspondents association
on sunday blasted president trump's
brief foray out of his hospital room to
wave to supporters from an suv calling
it outrageous
and criticizing the lack of transparency
around the photo op
white house correspondents association
president zeke miller said in a
statement it is outrageous for the
president to have left the hospital even
briefly amid a health crisis
without a protective pool present to
ensure the american people know
where their president is and how he is
doing now more than ever the american
public deserves independent coverage of
the president
so they can be reliably informed about
his health so it's terrible terrible
terrible
that trump would go outside also he was
endangering everybody
also why didn't we have reporters in the
car with him
so that's solid stuff right there that's
uh okay so what exactly
is trump's health condition as of right
now
apparently he's okay people are trying
to blow it out of proportion that he's
taking a steroid
okay lots of people take steroids i mean
seriously like steroids are a very very
common
commonly used medication they are safe
for use in children as designated by the
fda
the use of a of a clinical steroid in
order to
presumably help tamp down kovid or
or work on the immune system so it's a
tampdown covert that is not like the end
of the world
however there was confusion about his
condition
over the weekend we'll get to that we'll
get to that confusion in just a moment
first
it now looks as though pretty much
everybody around trump has been infected
with covid so trump's campaign manager
bell stephen bill stephen he tested
positive
for coven attorney general william barr
has not tested positive for covered but
he's going to self quarantine anyway
just in case for the next few days we
also have
chris christie being diagnosed and
christie obviously
is also in a high risk bracket
considering that he is obviously heavily
overweight
we we have a bunch of people who are at
the cleveland clinic debate who
apparently
got tested and um and came out positive
so this has turned into its own little
super spreader
core which is why again should the
president have been downplaying
the way that he the way that he did
masking right
just in his attitude not even in so far
as what he says but his attitude
no should there have been at this white
house rose garden ceremony people who
are hugging each other and all up on
each other even if they had already been
tested
probably not right none of this was kind
of cdc standard
i get it i get the narrative i do and
again
two things can be true at once for the
fifth time two things communal ones
botched by the white house media is bad
at this okay so
the new york times is looking at the use
of dexa methozone to treat trump
as suggesting that he had severe covid
according to the new york times
on sunday trump's doctors offered rosy
assessments of his condition on sunday
but the few medical details they
disclosed including his fluctuating
oxygen levels and a decision to begin
treatment with a steroid drug
suggesting suggested to many infectious
disease experts that he is suffering a
more severe case of coca-19
than the physicians acknowledged and
this is where we get off into cuckoo
land territory
so now we have the new york times and
many other publications
learning full-scale speculation about
the president's health while you have
actual doctors out there speaking about
the president's health
that seems irresponsible to me it seems
irresponsible
to have sanjay gupta you know talking
about the president's health condition
when he couldn't even correctly diagnose
chris cuomo
on air he said that chris cuomo had
leakage into his lungs which apparently
is not even a thing but over the weekend
he was like i don't trust the medical
information being put out by the medical
team now as we will see
there are some bases provided to this
distrust by the white house
communications team and the white house
and the white house doctors everything's
a mess everything's a mess
if the if this white house acted
professionally it would tamp down
two-thirds of the problems that have
happened inside this administration
easily
that's been the problem with this
administration from the very beginning
lots of great policy
horrible communication strategy all
right here's sanjay gupta on cnn
you got to be honest you got to be
transparent and all these details
matter i mean he's out he's coming out
to brief the public
about the president uh that that's
that's the briefing that's happening
uh if you're gonna do that then you have
to be absolutely honest and
it wasn't just sort of conveying an
upbeat attitude uh
he was it was purposely misleading
yesterday
about a very basic issue which is
whether or not the president
had been on supplemental oxygen okay and
so they've taken
whatever confusion came out of the white
house and then painted the gloomiest
possible
picture now is that because many members
of the media are actually kind of hoping
for the gloomiest possible picture for
trump and it's going to be anticlimactic
if trump emerges
with the v for victory sign and then
says i just did covet and you know what
it was not great but all right is that
gonna is that something they're gonna
live with
we'll find out in short order because it
appears the president is getting better
to the disappointment of a great many
blue check marks on the left
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you should not be headed out to the
auto parts store today in fact why would
you go to the auto parts store ever
they're just going to order you this
generic part offline that you can do
right now yourself
it's going to take weeks to get there
when it does get there they're going to
up charge you or they'll charge you
differently because you're not a
professional well why exactly would you
do all that instead
head on over to rockauto.com it's much
easier than walking into the store
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts and let's say you
happen to need a delphi fg 1456 fuel
pump assembly for 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey
that'll cost you like 354 bucks at a big
chain store
well that's the kind of thing you could
get at rockauto.com for 217 bucks
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts that rockauto.com
catalog it's unique it's remarkably easy
to navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got an amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need
rockauto.com so head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car trucking right
shapiro and then how did you hear about
us box so they know
that we sent you okay so over the
weekend the
the white house team the medical team
was not
particularly i would say transparent
about the health of the president of the
united states he could see the message
change
over time so on on friday
they said originally that he was
asymptomatic then they said that he had
mild condition then they said that he
had a moderate condition according to
mark meadows and then on saturday dr
sean conley who's the white house
physician
came out publicly and needed a depressor
in which he
kind of refused to give answers on
whether trump had received oxygen
he has not received any supplemental
option he's not on oxygen right now
that's right
he's not received any at all he's he's
not needed anybody any uh
this morning today at all has he ever
been on supplemental oxygen
he right now he is not on i know you
keep saying right now but should we read
into the fact that he had been preaching
yesterday and today he was not on oxygen
so he has not been on it during this his
covent treatment
he's not on oxygen right now okay so he
kept saying over and over he's not on
oxygen
right now and then saturday morning
sarah cook of nbc reported
that a source familiar with the
president's health said quote the
president's vitals over the last 24
hours were very concerning
and the next 48 hours will be critical
in terms of his care we're still not on
a clear path
to a full recovery and people on the
right went nuts how could sarah cook
report this it's an
anonymous source if you're going to say
something like the president might be
dying then you probably need to source
that well as it turns out the anonymous
source was in fact chief of staff of
mark meadows this is according to
jonathan swan over at axios here was
mark meadows on saturday saying
oh yeah he did actually receive oxygen
as it turns out now that doesn't mean
that conley was lying connolly was not
lying
right conley was doing the bill clinton
is is in the present tense and was
in past tense are you saying well you
know right now like this very moment
he's not on oxygen but
here's mark meadows getting rid of the
narrative the biggest thing that we see
is is that uh with a with no fever now
and with him doing uh really well with
his oxygen uh
saturation levels we uh yesterday uh
morning we were we were real concerned
with that you know he had a
fever and uh his blood oxygen level and
dropped
rapidly and uh and yet uh
in typical style this uh this president
uh was was up and walking around
okay so there you have mark meadows
undercutting the original narrative by
conway that trump was not on oxygen he
says no actually he did
have oxygen actually a couple of times
so then on sunday
conley was asked about why he didn't
actually just give
real information now it's pretty obvious
again from that original clip that he
was being studiously
uh i'll tell you studiously avoiding
saying that trump had been on oxygen so
then on sunday he comes out and he says
i was trying to convey an upbeat
attitude
i was trying to reflect the the uh the
upbeat attitude that the
team the president that his course of
illness has had
um didn't want to give any uh
any information that might uh steer the
the course of illness in another
direction
um and in doing so uh you know it came
off
uh that we were trying to hide something
which wasn't necessarily true um
and uh so here i have it he's he is the
the effect of the matter is is that he's
doing really well
okay so the last thing is the one that
matters but is this a good common
strategy no and as it turns out it was a
comm strategy
that was designed at the top as per our
usual arrangement
when professionals actually do the comms
things turn out okay
when president trump does the comms
things do not turn out okay meaning the
communications
strategy i mean this puts now the white
house doctor in a position of not really
being able to be believed
and sunday conley was asked about this
at the white house he was asked you know
how are we supposed to believe you when
you basically would not give us
information yesterday
yesterday you told us that the president
was in great shape had been in good
shape and fever-free for the previous 24
hours
minutes after your press conference
white house chief of staff mark meadows
told reporters that the president's
vitals were very concerning over the
past 24 hours
simple question for the american people
whose statements about the president's
health should be believed
so uh the chief and i work side by side
and i think his statement was
misconstrued what he meant
was that uh 24 hours ago
when uh he and i were are checking on
the president that there was that
momentary episode of the high fever
and and that temporary drop uh in the
saturation
okay so the way that they actually ended
up clearing this up is by saying that
originally the timeline had been
conveyed wrong
it wasn't over the prior 24 hours it was
it wasn't the prior 48 hours is over the
prior
24 hours people on the left have been
speculating that trump
tested positive as early as wednesday it
turns out that that is not the case as
far as we know
it turns out actually that trump tested
positive
i guess as of thursday and then after he
tested positive
uh in a rapid test on thursday he went
on sean hannity's show
and while he was on hannity's show he
didn't then convey that he had tested
positive because he was waiting for the
more certain pcr test to come back now
that's not lying right i mean if if you
test preliminarily positive in a rapid
cover test in your presence of the
united states and you're now waiting for
another test to come back
then and and somebody asks you and you
say i don't know yet that's not lying or
if you just don't volunteer the
information that's not really lying
either
it's not great like if if you're trump
probably just cancel the interview with
hannity
like why wouldn't you cancel him but
again comes strategy run from the top
and the great lie of the trump white
house for a long time is that trump
is a communications genius he is a
branding genius he is not a
communications genius these are two
different things
a branding genius is somebody who knows
how to put together a pithy slogan
somebody who knows to put together a
pithy pitch a a communications genius is
somebody who knows how to actually
message
complex ideas into the simple and how to
be transparent enough with the american
public that you gain their trust and
trump is not a common strategy genius he
is a very very good branding guy
that divide has never been greater than
it is right now
now with that said the media again have
lost their ever-loving minds over all of
this we've been told that him riding in
a car
literally was murdering people we've
been told that
his doctors are openly lying to the
american public how can we trust them to
the point where we even had people like
joy reid suggesting trump may not even
have covet maybe this is just a little
sympathy play
she said she was getting those sorts of
texts from her friends that lady has a
show
on msnbc we'll get to more of this in
just one second but it does point to
a shortcoming in the president's
personality that's being reflected in
the polls and it is common between the
debate and between the covet treatment
handling we'll get to that in one second
first
let's talk about the fact that when you
think of the future you think
of your dreams what you really should be
thinking of is your goals
because the fact is that you can achieve
those goals and many of those goals
can be achieved with a degree from
ashford university ashford university's
online bachelor's and master's degree
programs allow you to learn on a
convenient and flexible schedule
at ashford expert faculty will teach you
real world skills from real world
experience
in online classes built for life's
twists and turns you can learn from home
or wherever you feel comfortable you can
pursue a degree in one of ashford 60
plus programs
like business administration healthcare
administration and psychology
with 24 7 access to your classroom daily
support financial aid available
ashford will give you the tools you need
to go from dreaming to doing turn that
dream into an actual goal
your bigger future starts today at
ashford university there is no fee to
apply or standardized testing required
to enroll go to ashford.edu slash ben
you've heard me say before that the best
path to a successful future is to
constantly be upgrading your resume
ashford is a great way to do it go to
ashford.edu slash ben again that's
ashford.edu not all programs available
in all states also why would you be
paying like a fortune to go to one of
these bigger colleges that's going to
give you the exact same online education
right now
that ashford will give you go to
ashford.edu that's ashford.edu
slash ben and so president trump
apparently was running the com strategy
here
top down according to the new york times
he said i didn't want to give any
information that might steer the course
of illness in another direction it's dr
conley and in doing so
it came off that we were trying to hide
something which wasn't necessarily true
alyssa farah
who actually is very good at her job
she's a white house comms advisor
she conceded dr conley had been speaking
to an audience of one during his
saturday briefing quote
when you're treating a patient you want
to project confidence you want to lift
their spirits and that was the intent
well okay the intent of conley even
being if you don't want to go press or
down to oppressor but if you're going to
have a pressure then you actually have
to be transparent about the health
condition
what's amazing about this is that trump
is now mimicking a lot of the same flaws
as the hillary clinton campaign
in 2016. in 2016 there were serious
questions about hillary clinton's health
you remember this
right she was she kept coughing she
wasn't doing long interviews
and then you remember she kept saying
everything's fine it's fine it's totally
fine
and then she collapsed into a van and
then the answer was well she had
dehydration right that was the original
answer she got dehydrated and then it
turns out she had walking pneumonia or
something
okay and we had not been given that
information and people started to have
real doubts about her health well the
same thing has happened here with
president trump
now it looks like apparently according
dr brian garibaldi another physician
treating the president
that trump could be discharged as early
as today and head back
to the white house which of course would
be good in addition to steroids trump
has received an experimental antibody
cocktail
and is in the midst of a five-day course
of rem desperate which is an antiviral
the white house does have a medical unit
capable of responding
to the president's health troubles they
don't have the sophisticated equipment
available at walter reed but more of
that is for
evaluation trump apparently wants out
if his twitter account is any indicator
the president is feeling a lot better he
was pretty silent on twitter on saturday
blessedly and then on sunday night and
monday morning
he went wild on twitter and just started
tweeting everything in
the world apparently president trump was
very frustrated with a lot of the media
coverage
and so he had a conversation with rudy
giuliani reported by the daily telegraph
in which a daily telegraph columnist now
has unveiled the comment
says i have a good update for you from
rudy giuliani the former new york mayor
i spoke to him about an hour ago he just
got off the phone from the president
apparently the president gave giuliani
this statement quote
you can go and tell people i'm watching
this coverage which is basically saying
he's taking a turn for the worst
i feel i could get out of here right now
but they're telling me there can always
be a backstep with this disease
i feel like i could go out and do a
rally i'm presidents of the united
states i can't lock myself
in the room apparently the president
said i had to confront the virus so the
american people stopped being afraid of
it so we could deal with it
responsibly now that could be
president's actual
message coming out of this they're going
to be two dueling messages coming out of
covet
assuming that trump is fine god willing
okay message number one is gonna be the
one pushed by democrats he was
irresponsible his irresponsibility led
him
to be in rooms with people he should not
have been in rooms with he did not
protect himself and he did not protect
others
and in fact chris christie has said for
example that during debate prep trump
was not wearing a mask he was within six
feet of chris christie and chris
christie now has it
we now know that that senator tom tillis
has it we know that that senator mike
lee has it
like a lot of people who are in trump's
kind of immediate circle
they'll step in the president's campaign
manager has it you know that that's
gonna be the narrative this trump was
irresponsible
and so when trump got it it was just a
sign of his irresponsibility which again
is completely at odds
with the administration's actual
activity on cove this is one of the
great frustrations
it is a true frustration for me because
here's the deal here's what trump could
have done
back in march and april what if
president trump said you know what
lockdowns don't work lockdowns are a bad
idea what if trump had said this
a lot total lockdowns are a bad idea
because as we're going to see
what's happening right now is the debate
over trump's health and his
obtaining covid is now being telescoped
it's being telescoped into
the debate over broader lockdowns which
are going to re-emerge as we enter the
fall
what if trump said listen lockdowns are
bad strategy everybody
should go back to work if they are
healthy and they should wear masks and
they should socially distance
people are capable of being responsible
this is exactly the case i was making in
april
go back and listen to the show i
literally said lockdowns are a bad idea
and i trust people to be responsible and
by and large people are responsible
okay but it's easier to make that case
when you are not personally being kind
of irresponsible
it became even more politically inept
when he started doing these large
rallies i said
at the time on the show over and over as
soon as the democrats
said that it was morally admissible for
you to go out and protest and shout in
people's faces and spread covet as much
as you wanted
so long as you were shouting about how
the police were evil and america was
racist and george floyd
as long as you were doing that it was
totally fine trump should have said
listen i'm not doing rallies i don't
know why you guys are green lighting all
this stuff whatever happens next is on
you
i've said people should be responsible
you guys have engaged in pure
irresponsibility not only
on a moral level by backing anti-police
propaganda from the far left but on a
but on a health level you're being
irresponsible
by saying it's totally fine to go out on
the streets millions of people doing it
instead trump was like well you know if
they can do it i can do it let's have
some rallies and that of course allowed
the media
back in to say that trump was being
irresponsible and because trump is the
anti-lockdown
and then he got coveted the case is
going to be made that joe biden who is
pro-lockdown and has not had covet has
the right strategy here even though
again anecdotal evidence is not the
basis of good policy
but that's how people are going to use
it it's it was stupid
okay that i'm sorry that was a stupid
strategy and that's not an argument for
mass mandates
again my whole case is that people can
be trusted responsibly to put on masks
when the case loads are rising you see
this in l.a where everybody is wearing a
mask you saw this by the way in florida
and i was in florida for three weeks
during the uptick and people were in
fact wearing masks in widespread fashion
in much maligned florida by the way
florida texas
georgia all of them had a much much
lower second wave or first wave as the
case may be than new york
had and new york is now having a bit of
a second wave where it looks like
they're up ticking
into a second wave because when you lock
down very harshly
in consummate fashion you will have a
bump after the end of
that lockdown we'll get to more of the
public policy ramifications
of all this in just one second also more
kind of media craziness over all this
first
let's talk about a truly meaningful gift
that you can give to yourself or to your
family
i'm talking about a portrait like a
portrait like a full-on painted portrait
of you
or your family your kids your pets like
anything that's meaningful to you
you can do this and it's not going to
cost you a fortune and also you're not
going to have to sit there like some
sort of 18th century
french noble with your with your hand
and your shirt for like four hours while
somebody paints you instead you send
them a picture you want turned into a
portrait and they do it over at
paintyourlife.com i've got one hanging
over our mantelpiece right now with
paint your lights compilation portraits
you can bring together family members
who never even had the chance to meet or
you can create a portrait of the whole
family without the need for everyone to
be there for a family photo you can
order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes
it's meaningful personal and can be
cherished forever it makes a fantastic
holiday gift for somebody you love
or for yourself go check them out right
now text ben to 64
000 text ben to 64 000 at
paintyourlife.com
there is no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed right now is a limited time
offer get 20
off your painting that is correct 20 off
and free shipping to get that special
offer text the word ben
to 64 000 that's ben do 64
000 go check them out right now tech
spends 64 000 and get involved with
paint your life it is
fantastic they say great great gift okay
we'll get to more of this
in just one second how the democrats are
trying to turn this into political hay
but first in case you missed it we had
another great episode of the sunday
special yesterday
academy award-winning actor john voight
joined me to discuss his illustrious
acting career his journey to
conservatism and an inside look into
being a hollywood
conservative so head on over to
dailywire.com or listen on apple podcast
spotify or
wherever else you get your podcast i
love john as a person he's just a
wonderful wonderful dude
and it's a really really interesting and
fun sunday special a lot of hollywood
talk actually not as much politics
as sort of entertainment industry and i
think it's fascinating especially if you
love
classic and modern hollywood material
also
in case you didn't get enough politics
this week this wednesday october 7th
will be the vp debate between mike pence
and kamal harris
maybe one of the most consequential vp
debates ever since usually they don't
matter at all
this time you'll probably get the two
people who might in fact be president
considering that joe biden is uh not
looking fantastic out there
daily where's matt walsh will be live
reacting to the debate as part of a
special edition of all access live
members can join matt wednesday night at
8 30 pm eastern or 5 30 p.m pacific
at dailywire.com to chat live with him
on the live stream and
in the comments if you're not part of
the daily wire already join now as an
all access member get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all of our upcoming debate coverage live
at dailywire.com apple tv or
roku and join us on all access live
every night for live stream discussions
you also get not one but
two leftist tiers tumblers with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products that's this wednesday october
7th at 8 30 pm eastern 5 30 p.m pacific
join us get 20 off your all-access
membership with code debate
when you sign up today go make the magic
happen i'll access
you've been waiting to do it now you get
20 off when you use code debate you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
okay so there are two ways in which
democrats are attempting to play
this particular covid scenario into a
broader political discussion
way number one is they are trying on a
very practical level to kill the vote
for amy coney barrett for the supreme
court
right their goal is we have enough
senators who've been infected they need
to stay home
if they're at home they can't vote okay
there's only one problem with this the
virus either runs its course or it does
not run its course
once it runs its course that's usually
like a 10-day period the cdc says you're
supposed to quarantine
for 10 days once you are
post-symptomatic you typically are not
transmitting the virus
and once you are post-symptomatic you
might be doing some viral shutting but
it's not much
and there's not a lot of evidence that
once you're a post-symptomatic you are
really a grave threat
to anybody else also you're now immune
so i mean on on president's trump level
i think that there's a good shot that
within three weeks you see president
from body surfing the crowd
right that he actually just goes to
rallies and he's like whoo they grew
yeah just jumping out in the crowd
waving to people
and being carried around on their
shoulders eight of them and it's
that's a possibility but one of the
things the democrats are trying to do is
kill the amy coney barrett vote saying
there are not enough republicans
available
to vote because right now there have
been several republicans who've been
affected
mike lee has it uh senator ron johnson
from wisconsin
has it and senator tom tillis has it
well recall you this republicans right
now have 53 votes in the senate
susan collins of maine has already said
that she may or may not vote this way
and murkowski says she's not going to
vote this way so you actually need all
those people
present in order to get amy coney
barrett on the court democrats are
praying that republicans actually don't
have the scotus votes
according to the atlantic suddenly amy
coney barrett might not have the votes
for the moment coveted 19 diagnoses have
jeopardized three votes that republicans
can't afford to lose this according to
russell berman september 26th was a
festive day for republicans in
washington under overcast
eyes skies president donald trump strode
to a podium in the white house rose
garden to introduce judge amy coney
barrett
as his nominee to replace the late
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg
a military band played hail to the chief
and about 150 guests including senior
members of the republican party
the president's cabinet and the senate
sat shoulder to shoulder and mostly
without masks as they cheered for the
nomination of a 48 year old conservative
to a lifetime seat
the mood is upbeat in part because
barrett appeared to have the votes for
confirmation
before the president even uttered her
name just over a week later trump's rose
garden event suddenly seems far more
ominous
the idea of barrett's pre-election
confirmation is in doubt what had been a
celebration now appears in retrospect to
have been a super spreading catastrophe
the president is hospitalized with
covenant 19.
several infections of high-ranking
government and republican party
officials have been plausibly linked to
the event among those who have taken ill
are the chair of the rnc ronald mcdaniel
the president's campaign manager bill
stephen the current and former trump
advisors hope hicks and kellyanne conway
and the president of university of notre
dame
john jenkins the coronavirus cases that
could be the most problematic are mike
lee
tom tillis and ron johnson lee and telus
both serve on the judiciary committee
they could of course
have zoom sessions and they probably
will republicans have a 53-47
majority two of the members have said
they oppose holding a vote to confirm a
scotus justice
before the election the senate isn't
expected to hold the final vote until
the end of the month
but if these three senators couldn't
show up republicans would not have the
votes
it's also possible that more republican
senators will come down with the virus
in the next few days
apparently everybody is basically going
to quarantine for the next week or so
this is exactly what democrats are
desperately
desperately hoping for they've been
looking for some sort of miracle to
happen
and uh and like hans gruber they they
may get the miracle that they want
chuck schumer could barely conceal his
glee a little bit earlier
over the weekend as he says that
president trump put a lot of people at
risk and also by the way maybe we
shouldn't vote on amy coney barrett
we need full transparency we all know
the president's cavalier attitude
towards covet towards masks towards
social distancing
has endangered many people including
himself
as again this picture shows but it
happened over
and over and over again so now at the
very minimum we need full transparency
we need to know exactly the level of the
president's health
okay but is it really about that or is
it really about the political gain
well color me skeptical that it's about
the actual
human problems of covet 19 here
especially when the atlantic on the same
day
the running pieces talking about how the
vote for amy coney bear could be in
doubt read another piece
by quinta juretic a contributing writer
at the atlantic and managing editor of
law fair
and susan hennessey an executive editor
of law affair called the reckless race
to confirm amy coney barrett justifies
court packing they say
we used to reject court packing as a
dangerous game now we believe it may be
the best way to restore the court's
legitimacy
shocker they've now flipped and they say
that it is now time to just
toss justices willy-nilly
onto the supreme court very exciting
stuff
so it feels as though they have a
pre-existing narrative here and now
they're just looking for an excuse
to fulfill it okay so narrative number
one from the democrats is there aren't
gonna be enough votes in the senate or
even if there are people are gonna be
sick
and so we shouldn't hold hearings and so
just conveniently amy coney barrett
shouldn't make it on the court mitch
mcconnell's not gonna listen to that amy
coney barrett will end up on the court
then there is the second narrative that
is being promulgated
and that narrative is more damaging to
trump that narrative is
again he was not particularly careful
republicans have not been particularly
careful
and so when they say that you can be
trusted they can't even be trusted so
why should you be trusted therefore
lockdowns and if there are continued
lockdowns from now until the end of the
election
or from now until january or from now
until february the economy is just going
to skid
it is just going to go off the rails we
had an economic report last week it
showed that there was some 644
000 jobs added nationwide that's not bad
but it ain't great it's not like the
recovery is just doing amazing it turns
out that we are seeing
the recovery stall out for a wide
variety of industries including the
airline industry
and the and the theater industry regal
cinemas is now suspending operations at
all
u.s locations according to the wall
street journal they are the second
largest cinema chain in the united
states they're closing every one of its
locations nationwide after reopening
in august that followed cascade of
postponements for big budget hollywood
films most recently the new james bond
movie
the studio behind the film mgm holding
said friday it was delaying the film for
the second time to next april
from this november it had originally
been scheduled for release in april
of this year so they said that they
don't have enough movies
meanwhile you saw disney disneyland cut
like 28
000 jobs you saw that the airline
industry was cutting tens of thousands
of jobs
according to the national association of
theater owners if status quo continues
of small and mid-sized movie theater
companies will be forced to file for
bankruptcy
or to close permanently so these
lockdowns do have severe consequences
not just
for obvious industries like the theater
industry where you are packed tightly
into small areas
in confined spaces with air conditioning
and re-ventilation
but the airline industry which has
similar conditions
the restaurants industry where you're
going to see huge numbers of small
businesses
go under so as we hit the supposed
second wave season right as we hit
the cold season the flu season at the
end of the year as people begin to go
indoors because it's too cold outside
in the northeast there's going to be
widespread debate over what is the
proper policy
to take and with republic with trump
having gotten coveted
with ron johnson for example having
gotten coveted and then apparently
senator johnson who
i you know i know senator johnson a
little bit personally very very nice guy
but apparently
he went to an oktoberfest party while he
was awaiting his covet 19 test results
not kidding apparently according to the
daily beast he didn't reveal his
diagnosis until saturday
he apparently chose to attend this bash
on friday evening evening even though he
knew that trump and many of his inner
circle had tested positive
for kovitz 19. there's also talk about
when trump knew
that he was sick he knew that hope hicks
apparently was sick on wednesday and
then he went to a fundraiser anyway
johnson said that he only took his mask
off when it was time to address the
crowd he also insisted he was at least
12 feet from anybody
during his speech at the event which was
sponsored by the ozaukee county
republican party
he said i feel fine i feel completely
normal he said he didn't stick around to
mingle
at the dinner okay so these sorts of
stories don't look good
for the anti-lockdown advocates okay
that
they don't because again the case for
anti-lockdown is we can all act in
responsible fashion and we can go back
to work
these things are not only mutually not
exclusive they're mutually necessary
responsibility and ending lockdown both
of these things should happen
in tandem that is the case but the
democrats are fully invested
in many cases in full-scale lockdown
including in places like new york
so new york is now seeing a little bit
of an uptick new york city
over the over the past several days has
seen an uptick in number of diagnosed
coveted cases
so maybe a couple of weeks ago in all of
new york city they were seeing something
like 500
cases 800 cases if you go back to
mid-september they were seeing
at the at their peaks something like 900
cases 860 cases 880 cases
well over the weekend they jumped to
1731 cases
so this has led to talk of new york city
adopting restrictions in harder hit
areas
according to the new york times for many
weeks public health officials had
expressed concern
that a second wave of the coronavirus
would hit new york city which until
recently had achieved striking success
in beating back the outbreak after a
devastating spread that left more than
20 000
residents dead on sunday with those
fears growing mayor bill de blasio
announced an emergency crackdown saying
he intended to impose new restrictions
in 20 hot spots in brooklyn and queens
that have been experiencing rising
positivity
rates the plan is a major setback for
new york city amounting to the first
significant reversal in the reopening
and offering further evidence of the
challenges in curbing the pandemic the
city over the last month had taken
several strides forward allowing indoor
dining for the first time
becoming the first major school district
in the country to bring back children
into its public schools but under the
new restrictions de blasio would close
every school
public and private in nine of the city's
146 zip codes as well as all
non-essential businesses indoor and
outdoor dining and restaurants in those
areas will not be allowed even outdoor
dining right
now we are back to full-scale lockdown
under bill de blasio
now even as a person i like i happen to
be pretty coveted cautious right i have
parents who are 64. you know this right
when i was sheltering
i literally sheltered in place for
several months there with my parents
because i did not want to i didn't want
them to risk their health even today
when my parents are over with us we tend
to be outdoors when we are indoors my
parents wear masks
they wear masks around my kids i tend to
be much more coveted cautious
than some of the people who are on the
right but
even i believe that it is nuts to ban
for example
outdoor dining okay outdoor dining is
not a chief
vector of transmission schools
particularly for people who are under
the age of 10 right for small children
these are not a chief vector of
transmission it is one thing to talk
about closing middle schools or high
schools
once kids have a more mature immune
system apparently they can now pass it
to people
because their bodies act like adult
bodies but if you're talking about
five-year-olds they are not apparently
passing this in anywhere near the same
numbers and if they do get it they're
not really getting supremely sick
according to cvc statistics okay i can
quote you all of the cdc statistics
doesn't mean the risk is zero it does
mean that the risk is relatively lower
and the schools have been open in europe
for a long time without them becoming a
chief vector of
transmission de blasio said today
unfortunately is not a day for
celebration today is a more difficult
day the nine areas have large
populations of orthodox jews
communities where the virus has been
spreading rapidly and where public
health officials have struggled to
persuade many residents to adhere to
guidelines
on mass squaring and social distancing
those areas all have had positivity
rates in recent days of more than three
percent
some as high as eight percent in
contrast to the city's overall rate of
1.5
the reason for that presumably is
because in a lot of these orthodox areas
it is the time of the year where you go
to shul a lot right you end up going for
rosh hashanah yom kippur right these are
the big communal days
sukkot the high holidays and the high
holy days holidays
that this is the time of year when
people tend to get together in close
quarters it's a big problem in israel
this is why they've had military
lockdown particularly
in religious areas by the way i think it
is worth noting
i do i think it is worth noting right
here that the media's treatment
of orthodox jews and other racial groups
is quite disparate have you noticed this
whenever there's a spiking rate
and it happens among black communities
where it happens in hispanic communities
the answer is sheer american racism
brutal american racism
not spiking deaths right not spiking
deaths where you could theoretically
talk about differentials in medical care
although even there you're seeing those
spiking rates of death vary by
racial group ethnic group in europe as
well you're seeing it in canada
it's very doubtful that america's racist
medical system is really the problem
here okay but
even when there is a spike in cases in
the black community or in the hispanic
community the media will chalk it up
to endemic american discrimination and
racism and evil
when there is a spike in rates in the
orthodox jewish community in new york
it is because they are refusing to obey
mask guidelines and they are going in
enclosed areas
and then spitting on each other so by
the way i tend to think that the second
one is true
meaning that when you have a heavy
spread in a particular community you
might want to look at the activity of
the particular community
as opposed to differentiating the
communities based one
on the behavior of the community and two
based on the evils of the american
system just gonna note the media bias
there right if there's a heavy uptick in
urban chicago
in heavily black urban chicago then it
must be because america is a racist
place if there's a heavy uptick
in borough park in new york then it must
be because those terrible jews are out
there spitting on each other
and just notice noticing the disparate
treatment right here
apparently reactions to the restrictions
began to emerge from jewish leaders on
sunday evening after celebrations of
sukkot
ended at least the first couple of days
david greenfield who represented borough
park on the city council until 2017.
he said i think it's unfortunate new
york city continues to single out a
couple of hasidic jewish neighborhoods
where there are now 20 neighborhoods
with serious spikes
many of the 20 zip codes the city's
focusing on do have sizable numbers of
residents who are not jewish the new
restrictions could increase tensions
between them and the orthodox jews most
of the schools set to close our
non-public schools
largely issue vote that have been open
for weeks about 200 private schools will
close as well as 100
public schools as well okay so
as new york looks to close down again as
more and more blue areas look to close
down again
they're going to look at president trump
they're going to look at ron johnson
they're going to look at the republicans
and they're going to say you guys said
that people would be responsible and you
couldn't even
keep yourself from getting this thing
and you're inside the white house bubble
so trump could theoretically come out
and say right now listen i should have
been more careful i shouldn't i should
have socially distanced
i you know i'm in the upper age bracket
but he should also say
listen if you are careful number one you
will lower your chance of getting it and
having been through this the vast vast
vast majority of people who get it
do live according to the cdc's best
current estimate
if you are between the ages of 0 and 19
years old your chances of dying from
this thing
are extraordinarily remote like the the
infection
fatality ratio is .003
if you're 20 to 49 it is 0.0002
if you are 50 to 69 it is .005
right which means not five percent not
0.5 percent but 0.5
of a percent right and if you are over
the age of 70 then it's like 5.4
is your infection fatality ratio which
is still
you know means that the 94 of the people
who get it above the age of 70
are going to live now once you get above
the age of 80 then it starts to climb
pretty precipitously
trump could say all of that he could say
lockdowns are ill-advised we can all be
responsible and i myself
am now promoting that we should all be
responsible we'll see if he does that
i i have my doubts but this has some
pretty significant
ramifications for the future of lockdown
specifically over the next
few months okay it's not
it's not wonderful and the media play
right into it because the media
are all in favor of lockdown the media
wish to foster a sense of chaos
and it is irresponsible for the
administration to give that sort of fuel
to people who are looking for that fuel
to burn down a lot of elements of the
free market system
hey meanwhile final note here so i just
have to point this out because the
hypocrisy is so grand
so over the uh over the weekend 60
minutes
covered tara reid tara reid of course is
the woman who accuses joe biden of
having
sexually assaulted her back in the
senate in the early 1990s
60 minutes covered it in australia which
makes sense because we have tons of
american voters in australia
so really really well done 60 minutes
long before joe biden was a household
name across america
and here is my desk tara reid worked in
his senate office in the early 90s
in march this year reed came forward
with what she
said was the full story by then many in
politics and the media were already
questioning her version of events it's
an allegation that has received
little coverage this election and unlike
trump's accusers
tara has received a barrage of scrutiny
do you feel as though if joe biden
wasn't joe biden your allegations would
be taken more seriously
absolutely okay so i'm glad that uh 60
minutes saw fit
to cover tara reed in australia
do you think they would be covering
donald trump's accusers in australia but
not domestically here in the united
states yeah i didn't think so
okay well we will be back here tomorrow
with much much more
so make sure that you stay tuned for
that also make sure that you go
subscribe over dailywire.com
and use promo code debate for 20 off
because we have all sorts of good stuff
coming for you in the next few weeks we
grow closer to the election we are just
weeks away at this point it's gonna be
vital for you to tune in so we'll see
you here then i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick schien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
libs draw all the wrong lessons from
president trump's covid diagnosis the
president drops in national polls but
gains where it counts and
race hoaxes proliferate around the
country check it out on the michael
knowles show
you